i'm rob linden
i became interested in
deep learning which is a kind of a
blanket term for a range of
machine learning technologies including
deep belief
i became interested in that through my
work in the
london f-sharp user group so for that
reason
uh volpe is my open source project that
i'm going to tell you about today
is written in f sharp
that's uh probably a little bit too
honest for the audience right
so i i wrote it in f sharp because i'm
part of the user group
okay we'll rewind that just pretend i
never said that
if i did actually if you did ask me why
did you write it in f sharp i'd give you
a more convincing answer better sales
pitch
which is uh there's several reasons uh
one
the main one which is a deal breaker to
be honest is
there are libraries that let you uh do
the work on the gpu
now if you're doing uh if you're doing
machine learning you have to work on the
gpu
forget forget trying to do it on the cpu
this is massive
uh matrix multiplications uh
you're going to need the speed the gpu
gives you
now one of the issues with the gpu is of
course that
it's a bit of can of worms gpu
programming for anyone who's done it
how many people have cut their teeth on
gpu programming so about
a third of people anyone who has
knows that it can be a bit of a can of
worms i have
i have damaged my laptop so badly that
i've had to fiddle around in the bios
trying to get it working again
having done gpu work uh so given that
that's such a can of worms it gives me a
lot of security
and comfort to be working with a very
strongly tight static language like f
sharp
this is a this is a good thing f sharp
is i mean it's not
it's not extreme static typing like
haskell
but it's much more towards the static
typing end of the spectrum than
most functional languages but it's got
composability in which
as we'll see later is a very good thing
uh now i'm not saying here that i'm
i'm angling for contributions to the
project but
you know if you uh ever feel like
wandering over to my github and
uh asking me out for a coffee over there
and seeing how it goes then
come over i'll give you the address at
the end of the talk it's open source and
if you want to do some
cool if you want to do some machine
learning in a cool language like f sharp
then this is a good place to start
especially if you're a good
front-end developer or you've got any
experience at all in web sharper
web sharper is a set of tools for
writing
fully fledged front to back
web apps in in f sharp
so on the front end it translates it
down to html and javascript
all right let's try so let's uh take a
quick look at
um going to give a quick product history
of deep learning
and start at the end so where are we now
with with deep learning it's nice to if
you haven't done this already just go
and have a look at the
uh the images search in baidu what you
can do is you can
take photos from your camera you can
upload them to the
baidu search engine the chinese google
uh
and it will tell you what it thinks your
image is you know this is uh this is
quite powerful
and that's a that's an example of a deep
learning technology that's
uh that's up there in the wild right now
i for volpes i've gone to
back in the back in the level of
sophistication
i really work on mnest which is the
hello world of machine learning
examples mnist is a
it's a database of handwritten digits
there's a training set of
60 000 handwritten digits from a
statistical sample
that was carefully randomized and the
test set is
10 000 images written by different
people and the idea is
you run it on the training set you
identify these
uh these handwritten images with the
numbers they're supposed to be
representing
and you train your uh
you're training your neural net on the
training set
and you see how how well it performs on
the actual test set
and as you can see some of these numbers
are written
i mean written by a handful of
volunteers this nine
ask me any time i would have told you
that's an a
so it's actually quite surprising that
the good machine learning algorithms now
outperform humans on the
endless data set and actually the level
of success now in
in good systems is down to about
one percent and really i think when
you're when you're comparing a success
rate of 0.8 to 1.1
i think that's really nice i think
you've basically
you're basically by then assessing the
quality of the experiment rather than
the quality of your
network so networks today they've moved
beyond amnesty
they really test themselves on things
like imagenap which is a database of 15
million
labeled images taken from all over the
net
and that's what the cutting edge tools
are really working
on however mnist is still
it's still useful still useful if you're
like i was in f sharp writing a
neural net from scratch and you want to
work out how it's
doing i think i'm down to about four
percent errors or something at the
moment
um and
it's uh it's so it's also useful for
if you want to just see how a neural net
works how the edge dissection features
uh work at the lower levels
then endless is a very useful way of
just showing how this uh
how this feature recognition features
detection actually works
so it has its use it has its uses
it's worth saying that the deep belief
nat
algorithm is not of course confined to
to image recognition at its core
it's generic enough to handle pretty
much any set of inputs
so what one thing i've done in volpe's
which
is a difference between now and when i
gave this talk back in
april is i've added a concrete layer of
in direction so that uh the the the
layer that
uh that knows this is looking at the
mnist data set or
vision recognition is actually quite
small so
the core of the system works on inputs
outputs and signals and calls them
inputs
outputs and signals so if you want to
the the if you want to say right well
i'm going to start looking at
timit the the speech recognition
data set or i'm going to look at a whole
different classification problem like
here's someone's medical records have
they
are they a risk for breast cancer or not
the same algorithm can
can still work for those those kinds of
examples
so potted history of neural nets
uh i mean i say 1960s here
actually frank rosenblatt came up with
perceptron i think there was a paper in
1957 was his
was his first uh
his first introduction to the world of
uh
artificial intelligence and machine
learning learning it caused
at the time a lot of excitement which
later on turned out to be ill-founded
because the problem was more complicated
than i imagined
but the idea is if you've got an input
vector just a piece of data
uh x1 up to xn you multiply that by a
set of weights take a dot product
the j subscripts here are that denotes a
place in your
denotes an iteration step so
your first guess is w one naught w two
not
take a dot product uh feed that through
an activation function
if you exceed the threshold then you get
a
you get a one you get a firing if it
doesn't exceed the threshold you get
zero
so that gives you a kind of two stage
classification
problem and the perceptron what it will
do
is if that's a training set on your left
uh you know what the
you know whether or not you expect the
uh the neuron to fire
and if it does fire when it's not
supposed to or if it doesn't fire when
it is supposed to
you can update the weights accordingly
with that
and that that is the core of your
algorithm
now uh that is
it's that converges as long as your
test set is linear linearly separable or
you
your training set is linearly separable
and so for two dimensions that means
there's a line
that separates the two sets higher
dimensions it means there's a hyperplane
that separates the two sets
and in fact in higher dimensions that's
not quite as restrictive as
it is in the single dimension but
there's a huge class of problems
for which the perceptron just can't uh
just can't converge and one one of which
is the xor problem
and that's really one of the reasons why
after the initial
euphoria and the predictions of robots
making cups of tv or in the morning
uh the excitement died away and uh and
the whole fields kind of atrophied for a
little bit
fast forward then to the 1980s
and uh along came a paper
again jeffinson's name always comes up
with this
who who worked in the backpropagation
algorithm
and this is a form of layered learning
now this is uh
the idea here is you start with your set
of
uh your input signal if that's a that
could be an
image that's your input signal and from
that instead of trying to go straight
for the
uh for the final answer you
take more than one vector of weights you
take a set of vectors of weights and use
that to generate
some hidden units like an impression of
the
of the first input layer that you
started with
and then you can use those hidden units
those
that impression of your first layer you
can use another set of weights
to get an impression of that layer and
so on and so forth
until you arrive at your final
impression and again if this is a
training set you can take the difference
between the
the target that you're expecting and the
actual value at the end of the chain
and use the chain rule to go back down
and get weight updates all the way back
up the
back up the chain now turns out that
actually
the problem of uh linear
linear separability doesn't happen in
this this gets around it
and in fact rose and rosenblatt knew
that that was the case
uh all the way back in the 60s but uh
there have been
there's been controversy over whether he
did know that or not
it's worth just taking a little while to
say this is this is a stronger model
but also just kind of think about well
what's the what's the kind of biological
interpretation of this model
uh and i guess you know if you if you
imagine that you're
waking up in a in a dark room you're not
really perceiving where you are
you're you're in somewhere somewhere new
the first thing you're going to start
noticing is
lines and curves and
that's the that's basically your first
level of
hidden units that's the that's the first
initial impression you get
then once you've taken stock of all of
those
then you start moving up the chain a
little bit and you go from lines and
curves into
shapes triangles rectangles
color regions and then from then
those shapes you can start going further
up the chain and picking out individual
features
and so those triangles and circles and
rectangles and ovals might suddenly
start looking like
eyes or noses go one level up from that
you kind of aggregate those into a face
and then one level up up from that you
recognize the face okay that's
my wife that's my cat that's that guy on
the telly
and that final level of recognition is
your your kind of top layer
uh you can there is a school of thought
that says you can see what happens with
the lower layers
uh if you take acid which i'm not
suggesting that anyone does
but the school of thought says that um
what you're doing when you take acid is
you're actually scrambling the kind of
uh the v1 and v2 layers of your visual
cortex
again i don't recommend it
uh now let's let's step back from this a
bit
i mean this uh okay who's who's been to
talk some machine learning
and who's seen this picture i mean this
might as well be a logo for machine
learning
it's very very familiar um um i mean
remember i started this project in my
bedroom
uh so i want to give you a feel for
uh for actually how i interpret this
uh this model so i want to dive a little
bit deeper into the
uh into the back propagation algorithm
before we move on to beliefnet
problem with the backpropagation
algorithm can be slow
you've got to drive up your you've got
to drive your matrix
all the way through the layers to the
top then once you've got once you've got
your deltas once you've got your aero
signals you've got to drive it all the
way back through the layers
that can be slow you can end up with
very bad local optima
you can basically yes you'll get
convergence but you can end up
converting to garbage
possible problem anyway let's have a
let's have a quick look at how we
generate hidden units in practice go
back to this idea of the endless
database now the mnist
data set it's basically some 28 by 28
images
so you've got d
vectors effectively and the values are
in zero
uh the close interval zero to one
and that's your that's your input
signals and basically volpays
works on input signals that are vectors
with values in
zero to one so as long as you can take
initial
and initial signals and convert it in
that way to a vector like that
then then you can
run a back propagation algorithm and a
deep belief now so
the the hidden units are built up like
this
so i'm thinking of the hidden units as
as binary variables by binary variables
they're either zero or one
and the probability that the uh
that the neuron is going to fire that
the hidden unit is going to be activated
is given by the sum of the the weighted
sum
of the input layer plus a bias
and then you run that through an
activation function which
generally speaking looks like this it's
monotonic
increasing it's bounded above by one
it's bounded below by zero
and as long as you have a function that
satisfies those criteria
that's a decent activation function um
again when i first looked at this i was
sort of confused by
bias you know what does bias mean
and it took a little while to click the
clue is in the word
right so if you're biased about
something just
in in the every in the everyday sense of
the word that generally means you've
made up your mind before you've even
heard what the issue is
so if you imagine that bias is a really
huge number if it's a million billion
trillion
then whatever the input is from these
vis
the bias is going to overwhelm uh those
signals
and that neuron is going to switch on
whatever happens and the same
and similarly if it's minus a million
billion trillion
then you've got a negative bias and that
neuron is never going to fire you're not
going to see what's in front of your
face
but you know just for the sake of
mathematical elegance we can actually
incorporate that bias
into the weights matrix by pretending
that we've got v
naught which is one always one and then
we can just tack the biases onto the
left hand side of our matrix
and uh add a new add a new column the
biases become weights
and mathematically things start to look
very elegant
here i've got kind of a a weird hybrid
between math notation
and functional programming notation uh
so we take our visible unit vector we
prepend a value of one onto
on it for a bias and then we apply the
activation function to the dot product
of the weight
and that prepended vector so that there
you go that's the uh
that's the feed forward stage of our
back propagation algorithm that's how
actually works and that's how it's
implemented in uh vulpas
i wanted to go into that that level of
detail because
i couldn't find anyone actually
explaining that to that level on the web
and i'm not very bright so it took me a
while to work it out for myself
okay so that was the
1980s break breakthrough
moving forward to 2006 2006 is the date
that everyone talks about in
machine learning because that's when
belief nuts came around
invented by this chap jeff hinton
not to be confused with his doppelganger
um
i apologize now i actually stole this
joke from
one of the engineers at baidu uh and i
have to be honest i got the impression
from this guy that
uh jeff hinton is basically the rock
star of the baidu engineering community
i think if he showed up they would mob
him um
now his his contribution his uh
i mean maybe it was his grad student i
don't know uh
but his his contribution to the field
was
changing the question a little bit
he said well what configuration of
hidden units if
we've got a set of visible units
rather than thinking about moving up the
chain from
uh hidden units from visible to hidden
units you say well
if we've got a if we've got an input
vector what's the
what's a set of hidden units it gives us
the clearest picture of this
set of visible units that we've got in
front of us and that's a subtle shift of
of emphasis so we're not trying to get
the right answer anymore we're not
trying to say
this is a dog recognize it as a dog
we're just going to say right okay take
an impression of this
image that i've given you this this
input
and get the impression that
really captures the most information
that we can get from that
from that initial image and then choose
your weights
with that goal in mind rather than a
an attempt to try and
to try and put a label on something
before we really know what it looks like
or feels like
and the real and the real breakthrough
came in the fact that
rather than having to travel all the way
up through a network you can do this
kind of layered learning
a single layer at a time so
you can kind of work on reducing the
dimensionality
uh at the lower at the lower level this
is
this typical set of parameters that you
have once the job is done
at any one level then you take the
weights that come out of that that
you've corrected for each level
you can feed you can use those weights
to feed the input through to the next
layer
and then you can treat the next layer in
exactly the same way this is called
greedy layer wise learning and as
you can see each successive iteration
because we're
dealing with lower dimensions is quicker
than the
the previous layer so that's
unsupervised learning that's
pre-training
and um you know it's
it kind of makes sense again tying it
back to psychology
you know we learn what a dog is long
before we actually learn that it's
called a dog
so this is this this pre-trained step is
really quite a useful idea
and what you can do is you can train you
can
run this simulation you can get an
initial set of weights
then you feed back into your back
propagation algorithm the back
propagation algorithm is still the
workhorse of the machine learning
community
and that is the supervised learning
stage so a kind of a typical deep
learning would use a deep belief net
to do the pre-training and then once
it's got a decent set of weights
then it can put those weights that it's
learned into fine-tuning into supervised
learning and then it can start learning
proper labels for all of these things
that it's learned to recognize
and that avoids the problem of those bad
local optima
so the restricted baltimore machine is
there is the kind of magic ingredient
of the deep believe now
and a restricted boltzmann machine and
needs two
two uh two features that really let it
work its magic and those two features
are that the
hidden units have got to be independent
of each other and that for your sigmoid
function you have to have a
very uh special activation called
logistic sigmoid
uh it's a very common uh function in
in all areas of statistics
and as long as you have that those two
conditions met
your restricted boltzmann machine your
single layer can work
a really nice piece of magic and this is
what the magic is
right so like we said we've already seen
what the formula
looks like for going forward up the tree
we've got a weights matrix
uh the probability that hidden units uh
gonna fire given a set of visible units
is determined by that
that weights matrix but here's the
really cool thing about restricted
boltzmann machines it works the other
way
so given the set of hidden units that
same weights matrix that you've used to
generate the
the hidden units from the visible units
can be used to generate the
visible units back from the hidden units
you can go up and then back down the
network
with the same weight matrix you've got
um
as i say you've got biases there that's
fine you can incorporate
the biases the bs can become
the left hand column of your big weights
matrix
the a's then become the top row and then
once you've got that
you've got a full you've got a single
set of weights taking you forwards and
backwards through the machine
and there's a couple of lovely kind of
elegant
beautiful closed form formulas that let
you start tran
uh traveling through your net
so how what do our updates look like
we're nearly when we're nearly there
uh so how do you how do you get your
weight updates well what you can do is
you can travel forwards and backwards
forwards and backwards
through uh your machine until you get
convergence or until the end of time
whichever comes first
and then given that you can take an
outer product of the visible and hidden
units
one and then at infinity subtract the
two and then you've got your weight
updates
uh waiting till the end of time i mean
it's fine if your doctor who
slight problem if you're the rest of us
now what you can do is you can do this
it just turns out that actually up down
up is enough
i feel guilty about being so glib about
that because it took jeff hinton a long
time to realize that was the case
and it took him even longer to
mathematically prove that that worked
but for us we don't care right
it's just enough for us that uh it does
work
and that you don't have to worry about v
infinity h infinity
these are the updates that we're
interested in this is our gradient
function
the uh one minus two
we have it well not quite there's one
little
uh little uh point you don't want to end
up overfitting your data you don't want
to end up with a
a set of weights that fits your training
set perfectly and then as soon as you
have a tiny deviation from your uh
training set it gives you garbage again
so uh you have a momentum term
that helps you to to overcome any of
these
um any of these problems with
overfitting
and the momentum term basically
remembers what the last update was
and gives you a small contribution
in that direction to your next update so
that's what it looks like that this is
what the
formula looks like uh
it's really quite nice and simple this
log derivative is the
weight update from the outer products
and
the the alpha times delta w
n is your is your a weighted sum of your
previous
uh work now i've seen i've i've seen in
um
i've seen a matlab implementation of a
deep belief
net that had etas and alphas actually
written in the code
to which i say well look we're not
mathematicians
we're software developers right i've got
a better name if you're going to
if you're going to have a learning rate
which is uh eta and a momentum which is
alpha
how about a better name for that which
is learning rate and
momentum
so those are the things that you're
going to find in the vulpas code
uh there's no heaters and no alphas no
greek letters at all
yay
right so that
this this goes even further and this is
now kind of
wandering into
what vulpas does i use discriminated
unions
and that means that
i have a set of
uh parameters that i express
uh as types and then when i when i have
a function
that takes in these parameters they're
not expressed as primitive obsessed
int they're uh actual
uh they're actual parameters that that
feed into my my machines so this
is where the functional elegance of f
sharp help helps you write very robust
code remember i was saying earlier about
about having a statically typed language
that really helps with machine learning
so that's what this this looks like
to do matrix uh matrix multiplication
uh we've got to use gpu best knowledge
i've found for learning gpu is think
about a plumber and the reason it's a
good analogy is because when a plumber's
in your kitchen
they can get tools out of their bag
that's a
an analogy for memory in the most local
cache
but they might have to they might have
to go out to their van to get a tool
they might have to
you might have to go back to his
workshop drive all the way back you
might have to order parts from suppliers
and there's analogies between those
processes
and going back to different levels of
your cache different levels of memory on
the cpu
the gpu has a different approach that
means you invite
thousands of little plumbers into your
kitchen
and they all are equipped because you
equip them all with the small amount
each one needs uh
now in cuda c uh a kernel would look
like this the little plumbers
would be that's obscured here there's
accudency has a
underscore underscore global that tells
you you're in a kernel
and that means you're running off device
memory so
the point is up there i don't know if
you can see that but there's pointers in
the signature of the kernel
that are on the gpu
threads and you activate that from the
cpu
uh using uh
using cued and malloc and cuda mem copy
now notice that
uh this is one of the issues with q2c
that i don't like uh on the one hand
we've got pointers
to device memory on the one hand we've
got pointers to host memory
but the compiler can't tell the
difference between the two
and that can be a source of uh very
strange
bugs and problems so i use
uh yeah so this is uh two levels of
reality here there's host and device
big plum and little plumber now in f
sharp you've got
you've got more sophistication i work
with something called layer cubase
that's the url that's the web url
quantalia.org and
you write kernels slightly differently
in layer cubes you use them using
code quotations which are basically
expressions they've got all the metadata
and you can create a code quotation at
runtime so the output of this function
binary operation kernel
is actually a cuda kernel
that you can fire up with your own
launch logic
so in this case as say before when i was
in q2c land
you had to write a specific kernel to
add two
vectors together right that's the adding
two vectors is the
hello world of the uh of the gpu
programming uh uh
set of problems
so here i've got my binary operation
kernel i can actually feed in
a an expression into that function
and then at runtime it's going to create
a kernel for me
out of that expression so that's an
advantage over the c language
q to specification another example is
that we've got strongly tight
pointers there is no way in
queue to hear that i can mess things up
by
passing in a pointer that doesn't point
to an address on the
on the gpu
so this is how you build this is how you
build one of these kernels at runtime
the let bang basically says that you're
you're in a
that's a syntactic sugar for a bind
operation of a monad
and that leads you on to the next topic
which is saying look an alia cubase
we don't just have the host the big plum
we don't have to have the device
we've got a cuda monad which is like a
marshalling layer between
your big plumber your little plumbers
and
that man uses all of your launch logic
and the ma and the mappings between your
host
memory and your device memory and that's
really really handy for
building my deep belief net uh with f
sharp
using alloy cubase so as always as i
hinted at the beginning
here's where we get the composability of
uh of a functional language and we can
really turn it to our advantage
because the output of one kernel becomes
the input of another
and that's great because actually launch
logic is cheap
what's expensive when you're doing cuda
programming is copying memory across
from the host to the device and back
but if in your main loop all you're
doing is launching kernels
and using the output of the previous
step as the input of the current step
then that's then you're in a really good
shape i think it takes about 70
microseconds
to launch a kernel so
this is immediately a good thing and
let's look at a quick example of this
and this is the kind of thing that does
happen in my code if there's time at the
end i will show you some of the code
base
of the of the deep belief net that i'm
working in
so if you imagine you want to add a
vector
and multiply the result by a scalar this
is a syntax you'd use in the queue to
monad
so so you define the kernels one of
these is this binary operation kernel
and you have another scalar multiplied
kernel
the output of the monad is this function
this
function from x and y and
a scale and that function then
once you've built that function using
the compiler
then you can use that function to do
this operation
and it will do the operation it will
take the uh
it will take the quantities x y and
scale
that are all defined on the cpu it'll
copy them over to the gpu for you
it'll do the calculation on the gpu then
using that gather function
it will give you the result back and
translate the back onto the gpu so
this is how you would actually use the
cuda monad in aliacu basics it's
extremely
extremely elegant uh so i've got
in fact that should be add vector and
scalar multiply templates so that's the
typo
uh use that add vector programmers add
vector and scalar multiply template
load uh compile that
and then when you call run what you're
doing is you're
invoking this i think this must be an
old version of the slide that i've got
because i remember
correcting this earlier never mind
there you've got your function that
comes back
so all you need to do in real life is to
call run
on the add vector program or the add
vector and multiply by scalar program
and then that does all the job for you
and puts you in a good place
gather and scatter that's the way to
copy memory between the
host and the device i'm going to say
that and
of course you've got the worker.malloc
but worker.malloc in
internally will be calling the scatter
function
okay so i think i'm going to try to
just show you i mean that's the that's
the toy example
but i would like to
if i can show how this
translates into code can you um
however i'm not you i'm not sure that i
can i can see the
i can see my uh idea on the screen
oh there is okay right
this is going to be interesting
okay that's fine i'll i'll
locate i'll locate the relevant piece of
code and then i'll put it on the screen
so if i go into cue to templates
tell you what let's uh we're a little
bit push of time so i think i'm just
gonna
do it the uh the low-tech way
so running running through this seeing
what the code actually looks like in in
practice
so this is the this is the kernel so the
main loop what happens is
uh inside the main loop of the monad
you get to say uh
this this loop that loops across the
batteries of of inputs your that you're
looking at and what you'll notice is all
you have inside the main loop is launch
logic
right so you launch the forward
iteration that
takes you from your v1 to your h1 then
you go backwards to populate v2
forwards again and again look it's
launch launch launch
that's all it is so we've got this
composability going on very nicely here
then you compute your c1 and your c2
your positive uh updating your negative
update add those two together
and then that gives you the weight
updates
then you move on to the next part i do
have a gather here
but that's just uh just for reporting
purposes
so every every hundred iterations or so
you will gather the information and then
that tells you
how you're doing in your simulation
so that is pretty much a potted
example a demonstration of
how i uh how i will work a
deep belief in my gpu um
what i'm going to do now is give you
uh my
my twitter and the github address
so if anyone wants to
if anyone wants to contribute
or to have a look at the code base then
that's how you do so if anyone's got any
questions
fire them at me um thank you guys very
much for listening
does cubase work in mono um
i think it does right i can't stake my
life on that but um
but the uh the the the guys at cubase
are quite
um they're quite committed to
making work across as many platforms as
possible so
i believe so but do check the quant alia
website to just make sure so
yeah i think so is the answer to that
question does cubase work in mono
anyone else yep
question is volpe's is open source is
cubase
answer no you can
uh you can fire up a trial version of
cubase
and to be honest the the licensing isn't
that expensive i think
i paid about 30 pounds for a year or
something
something
like that so i'm quite i'm quite happy
because i'm interested in this material
to
uh to pay the guys and to be honest the
help that they've given me
in building full pays uh
it's worth a lot more than 30 quid
put it that way
cool all right uh yeah couple more um
uh is the thing that gets sent
um what gets what gets sent to cuda
uh is a what is a compiled function that
you can then call
um yeah that forms an operation graph
yeah is there a is there a value that
you can say this is my operation graph
for example if you want to write off
like an optimizer that runs it off of it
off from the zipper but
uh on operation graphs and transforms
them into more efficient ones like could
you do that in a generic way or
would you have to like add some extra
you know abstraction
i'm gonna put my operations in here i
think to be honest you would have to
you would have to do some extra work to
do that um
but you know again that that that's a
case where you get in touch with the
with the cubase guys
and they can they they can tell you very
quickly whether you can
uh whether you can do something or
sometimes they might decide it's worth
doing a bit of extra work and helping
you out with that i mean potentially
um they're gonna have a look at um
providing an api to the
nvidia's new qdn
which is uh quite an exciting
development nvidia have basically
announced uh a whole
deep learning library that's going to be
part of their
their interface and as i say it's very
much in my interest to be able to access
that from
from cubase
go to jeff uh no loads
loads of places but the two the two best
guys sorry the question was where's a
good location to get papers
uh and presentations for deep learning
um
the two the the kind of superstar
is jeff hinton so if you go to jeff
hinton's webpage there's lots of
resources there
his talks his talks make sense when
you've kind of dipped your toes into
machine learning a bit more
if you're new to the field i recommend
talks by
andrew known who's uh i think in the
same department as jeff hinton
or or has worked in the same department
uh
his his his talks are still conceptually
sophisticated but
i tend to find them more approachable
than uh hinton's work
hinton's work does make sense but i
think
it only starts to make more sense when
you've
got got your got your bum wet in the
code a bit more
okay and anyone else yeah are you aware
of anything
comparable specifically
uh no i'm not a nordic base i mean i was
talking to them in march
and um i'm the only guy well
as of march i mean things may have
changed but uh
as far as as far as they knew i'm the
only guy who's doing any
uh deep learning in uh
in their platform you know mind you six
months is a long time so maybe that's
changed
okay we're done
we're done thank you